c'est plus possible ma mère me disait
que j'allais mourir un jour quoi parce
que je me cache tenait la gauche prenait
de la drogue qui prenaient de l'alcool
je voyais pas ça comme un problème moi
j'ai deux comme ça et un final non c'est
pas ça
ma mère est envoyé dans des états où je
finisse à l'hôpital je finissais dans un
caniveau
quand j'arrivais ici la cheffe hammadi
et toi si tu as passé la nuit
j'étais pas bien toi va bien je me suis
qualifié loi à la cigarette
j'étais dans le match
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu pars de temps dans ma cellule et
voilà c'est ma famille ma petite soeur
ok avec moi ma grande soeur et ma nièce
et mes deux chiens sky et camille
[Musique]
oui
plus tout petit
j'ai des problèmes d'un pull civic et
parce que voilà par rapport à mon enfant
j'étais battu tout ça à peu près à
partir de 11 ans j'ai commencé à boire
un petit peu puis après c'est passé à 2
litres d'alcool fort par jour et cela
depuis 2008 je suis passé à 4 litre
d'alcool fort par jour parmi les tout ça
je travaillais donc
travailler en sentant l'alcool et en
titubant c'est pas cool
donc j'y arrivais à cacher l'odeur de
l'alcool et il va pour pas tituber et
puis pour être vraiment inquiet ben
voila je prenais de la coke en même
temps j'ai fait une soirée et
il y avait de l'alcool et le mec qui
était là je reconnaissais pas de trop et
du coup il a commencé il a faim il ya eu
des propos envers ma femme qui était pas
raisonnable et je me suis vite emporté
avec l'alcool et puis en plus je suis
impulsif et voilà du coup bah ça s'est
battu et et voilà il a porté plainte et
je suis rentré
[Musique]
dans cette unité donc les écussons on va
dire en quartier ouvert c'est-à-dire que
les quinze cellules sont ouverts
personnes enfermées dans sa cellule tout
au long de la journée
les journées sont divisés sur différents
temps on va avoir la salle collective on
va pouvoir effectivement se retrouver
pour voir travailler sur les émotions
travailler sur le pourquoi je consomme
et qu'est ce qui m'amène ici et qu'est
ce qui m'a amené à ces comportements la
halle à plusieurs règles sur l'unité
comme le fait de ne pas consommer de
produits psychotropes quel qu'il soit
seul le tabac est acceptée sur sur
l'unité et les traitements donnés par un
médecin bien sûr ce que je trouve un peu
effectivement difficile en prison c'est
par exemple le cannabis est omniprésent
demain vous êtes-vous dépendant au
cannabis dehors il va falloir déjà
savoir où est le lieu où est-ce qu'on en
vend qui est la personne qui vend ici
toute personne est susceptible d'en
vendre
vous n'avez juste à appeler à travers la
fenêtre vous dire que vous avez besoin
d'un bout de shit quelqu'un vous
répondra il peut arriver effectivement
que le soir individuellement dans la
cellule et des consommations
le but étant qu'ils arrivent à le
verbaliser le lendemain matin
[Musique]
le thème du jour c'est l'émotion qu'elle
quelle soit vous la choisissez sur
l'émotion
soit une émotion du passé soyez motion
très positif sur une émotion très
négative je suis stressé juste de sortir
nord d'affronter la vie et à vie a bien
qu'elle y affronter les produits et
quand je me suis préparé ch et b
l'espagne 8 rester avec moi je trouve ça
me josée confiant parce que
l'outil de plus en plus de confiance en
moi j'ai de moins en moins juste avant
que j'intègre j'étais dans un autre
bâtiment de cette prison et j'avais mon
voisin de cellule qui faisait de
l'alcool qu'il a distillé tous les soirs
et du coup j'avais toutes les vapeurs
d'alcool et l'odeur tout ça qui venait
dans ma cellule et ça me donne est
vachement envie
du coup j'ai décidé d'intégrer l'ue rude
pour vraiment ne plus ne pas voir se
produire à côté de moi et
et ne pas pouvoir résister à cette envie
et draw chuté vu qu'on est tous entre
nous et qu'on a tous la même volonté
d'arrêter qu'on a tous d'essayer
d'intégrer cette unité justement pour
arrêter nos addictions et ben du coup
ben y'a rien qui tourne et on est tous
entre nous soit lieder pour voix là si
quelqu'un a envie de consommer on va
aller le voir
on va essayer de le remonter le moral
tout ça et sans lui enlève son envie
avec toutes les activités et le fait que
j'arrive amoureux découvrir et à me
reconnaître
et ben là c'est mon gars c'est le petit
monde des enfants qui revient adultes et
j'ai envie de le garder parce que moi
c'est un mec bien
après mon incarcération je compte
continuer à un suivi avec justement des
spécialistes des addictions de colle
tout ça pour encore plus mais d après
lui ruhl parce que l'uruguay c'est bien
mais à la sortie
toutes les tentations les magasins tout
ça et du coup il va me falloir un suivi
tout soit toutes les semaines sont
toutes les deux semaines pour continuer
ce travail que je fais sur moi et parce
que moi mon but c'est abstinence 0 même
une bière ou quoi que ce soit je veux ne
veux plus je me sens beaucoup mieux et
heureux et
je content d'être venu à nouveau et ça
m'a fait comprendre que j'étais vraiment
commis avant et ma famille quoi les
pauvres qu'ils ont dû endurer avec moi
parce que je me rendais pas compte